c'est historiquement que l'alsace est
très touchée par des lettres beaucoup
plus touchés que cette nos autres
régions de france
en fait c'est à que l'alsace c'est tout
le grand nord est de la france je dirais
ou nerd les lignes entre la normandie et
la franche comté rhône alsace et 200000
personnes qui sont diabétiques ce qui
est quand même considère à 10%
la population dont 20000 qui sont
diabétiques ne le savent pas donc tout
un problème aussi de dépistage et donc
de retard à la prise en charge se tait
beïda sûr il est lié à un comportement
d'une population c'est bien clair la
pollution alsacienne a besoin du nord de
la france en général un comportement
très différents et aussi une exposition
des facteurs de risque très très
différent de du sud de la france mais
alors pourquoi pas de nos questions les
gens disent traditionnellement
l'alsacien manche revient il mange
beaucoup de celles beaucoup circuiterie
beaucoup de fromages du bois de la bière
pas toutes choses que l'on sait pas très
bonne ces bons moments se prononce ici
jouent un rôle mais ceci est une raison
et la raison c'est en fait celle qu'on
voit maintenant dans l' il y avait
partout dans le monde
le diabète est d'abord une maladie dégel
semmadi génétique et les jeunes qui vont
être les jeunes du diabète sont les
jeunes qui auront permis à l'espèce
humaine de survivre face à la famine de
survivre face aux grandes agression 2
l'histoire on est on capable de manger
peut y en a autant capable de se
dépenser beaucoup ces jeunes là lorsque
les conditions ne sont plus là ils
deviennent des jeunes d'une maladie si
on réfléchit un tout petit peu le nord
de la france toute l'alsace a été depuis
trois siècles
le témoin de toutes les grandes
invasions des allemands et polonais les
allemands et suédois et allemand les
allemands qui font que finalement cette
région a eu beaucoup plus de
problématiques de famine de souffrance
et que cette condition ces facteurs là
je vénère favorise l'émergence de jeunes
de sociétés qui sont des reines de lutte
contre cela si vous êtes s'ajouter au
fait que chaque fois qu'on a une grande
souffrance
on ne ressort avec un comportement de
l'enrichissement de stockage de poésie
et éviter que ça revienne
on comprend très bien que l'alsace le
nord de la france soit beaucoup plus
touché notre cuvée les casas siens un
peu responsable notre cahier pas
coupable le couple c'est l'histoire de
cette région qui est très différente de
l'histoire du sud de la france et j'ai
tout peut être une chose c'est que quand
on regarde comment ces différences
nord-sud
on la retrouve aussi au niveau de
l'exposition au soleil et que la région
la plus touchée par diabète
c'est la région la moins exposée au
soleil et que la région la plus protégée
salariaux le plus les exposer au soleil
et on sait aujourd'hui que le soleil les
rayons solaires sont un phénomène de
régulation de la santé extrêmement
important non seulement pour la vitamine
d qui vont amener en activant mais aussi
parce que au niveau 2
l'oeil la rétine il stimule des aigles
anc épiphytes notamment et ceci est un
facteur de protection contre thêta ii
maladie le diabète le cancer
mais attention la dépression c'est donc
il ya aussi indiscutablement celle de
sion là là aussi la dacia n'est pas
coupable
j'ai subi le diabète en france
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 4 millions
de personnes
à titre d'information autour des 1 90 et
qui lui sont bien donc on est passé de
800 milles à 4 millions dans le monde
on est passé durant la même période qu'à
peu près 80 millions à 466 millions et
on est certain qu'on dit oui 40 dans le
monde on sera entre 800 millions et un
milliard de personnes affectées par
cette maladie qui veut dire que c'est
une épidémie véritable c'est la première
épidémie dans l'histoire de l'humanité
du mahdi qui n'est pas contagieuse
jusqu'au xxème siècle toute manière
épidémique t des maladies contagieuses
tuberculose le grip choléra si la
toussaint selmani porté par un vecteur
que l'on se transmettait dans le cadre
dans le cas du diabète mais aussi
d'autres manient qui arrivent et
d'attention elle a déjà des pressions ll
n'ya pas l'agent qui transmettent la
maladie et il ya deux facteurs qui
interviennent et qui est elle très
fortement ce les facteurs génétiques ce
dont nous avons hérité de nos parents
nos grands-parents et de génération en
génération et les facteurs
environnementaux est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que cette discordance
monstrueuse entre en environnement qui
change les vitesses incontrôlée et des
jeunes qui eux ont encore l'expression
est l'une des expressions les plus
récente c'est que les jeunes pour
protéger l'homme leur rendent obèses
parce que c'était la bannière il ya 300
400 500 ans de surveiller vos familles
et aujourd'hui c'est encore pas faire
autrement
donc les jeux les plus prisés les plus
protecteurs sont ceux qui voient en
déjouant buzz dont 40 il tique donc
réclamé le même mécanisme qui était
salvateur il y a qu il ya cent ans 200 à
300 sur laquelle l'humanité n'existerait
plus
y'a pas immobilisé aurait pu être humain
sur terre et bien ce même mécanisme à
cette même anneau mais cette même
situation devienne maladie grave qui
donne des maladies graves dans le
diabète bien entendu alors en alsace et
deux cent mille personnes seraient dus à
peu près deux millions d'habitants
manquent c'est son heure ce sont des
complications complications qui sont en
fait le seul enjeu de la maladie parce
que à votre succès pas grave mais
problème c'est que ça favorise les
complications cardiovasculaires donc la
marque us l'action d'inspiration de
brasles l imputation qui sont vraiment
ce qui coûte plus cher la société est le
plus cher de l'individu c'est aussi des
risques suscités c'est aussi des restes
de dialyse en nasa pour donner un
chiffre
un dialysé sur deux est diabétique en
normandie c'est un sur 10 pouvant très
un type la différence donc non seulement
on a un deal est fréquent dans un
diabète qui est propre ou plus agressif
que plein d'autres régions de france
alors ça c'est peut-être lié un élément
qui est très problématique en alsace qui
à la consommation de sel
nous sommes les plus gros consommateurs
de sel pourquoi probablement encore ce
comportement est où le sel était comme
le sucre et les libres de survie face à
ces grandes ces grands drames et met
clairement l'ennemi de l'alsacien sait
bleu sur la table de repas à la rigueur
tout petit salaire en argent dans le
calme mais quelques grains et mieux pas
de salir du tout parce que discutables
comme le sel est un élément sûr lesquels
on peut agir assez facilement à la tasse
bien sûr deuxième élément sur lequel on
peut agir seule activité physique
là encore on est beaucoup moins
d'avantagés que le sud de la france où
il fait généralement et que faire du
vélo le sud de la france est toujours en
d'honneur faire du vélo ici pendant les
six mois de c'est quand même quelle
héroïne et c'est vraiment avoir envie de
faire alors on sait penser aujourd'hui
que l'alimentation de l'ue par
l'activité fini d'autre part sont les
grands responsables du diabète aux 600
et 1000 un traitement du diabète en
d'autres termes quand on bouge on reçoit
de son diabète
quand on est sédentaire en favorise
l'apparition du diabète et d'un problème
entation quand on mange bien on l'a mis
là où le diabète voir andy vite son
apparition
quand on mange mal est un féru de
l'apparition alors ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on a eu beaucoup de peine à
comprendre parce que c'est délicat très
long terme il faut 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans
d'alimentation de malbouffe entre
guillemets pour que le pancrace commence
à battre de l aile et que le diabète
apparaît ce que tu devais c'est la
conséquence d'un pancrate qui va pas
bien il faut des dizaines des 15 10 15
20 ans de sédentarité pour qu'un pont
crise commence à battre de l aile il en
avait pas la comprendre
on le comprend aujourd'hui parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte que on a deux glands
dans l'organisme qui sont
extraordinaires de glandes endocrines
sont l'une l'intestin et l'autre le
muscle l'intestin pour l'instant été
pour nous un organes digestifs
c'est aujourd'hui la plus grande de
glandes endocrines notre organisme est
en fonction de la flore intestinale que
l'on adoré test
les hormones que l'état s'est embrouillé
au programme vont varier avec si vous
avez une bonne flore intestinale de ce
que vous mangez bien équilibrée des
fruits des légumes
et puis vous aurez une bonne flore
intestinale vous aurez des hormones de
l'intestin qui marche combien et vouloir
prendre kraz qui ne va pas de visa
beatty basse et paris niveau du muscle
serment découvre depuis une dizaine
d'années et on est vraiment à la pointe
du travail là dessus
chaque fois vous contractez un muscle
vous envoyez des hormones dans votre vie
et la table on vous aurez des ordres le
pont classe et selon le type de muscles
vous contractez seo remonteront va être
favorable pour le plan classe donc
protégé diabète ou la vigueur et s'il
existe ou défavorable en l'occurrence
favoriser l'apparition et on sait en
particulier que les muscles de
résistance le triceps contrats mensuels
fut conduit le plus sont beaucoup plus
intéressants que les muscles d'environ
ce pourrait être le corps et cèpes ce
mois-là en scène en tout ceci fait que
on a une reconsidération et que on nous
à nous avons isolé en train de breveter
une new kids on the block in this
hormone fabriquée par le muscle une nuit
au kiel qui est manifestement capable
d'empêcher la destruction des cellules
pancréatiques pas le démettre
et c'est plus haut qui à mon avis dans
kill cinq ans qui viennent ce sera
l'arrivée d'un médicament extraordinaire
qui va être médicaments où on va
reconsidérer tout ce qu'on a vu qu'on
siècle à présent on peut plus parler à
insuline nph leur apparaît en amour de
l'insuline des éléments qui sont les
éléments régulateur de fonctionnement du
camp classe avec une nation qui peut
être important qu'elles sont de
prévention des contenus utilisés sur des
les manches et quand on sait qu'ils sont
prédisposés au diabète par la famille
par leurs histoires personnelles par des
tas de tout élément donc en est à l'aube
d'une nouvelle ère il ce qui est à peu
près sûr c'est que le muscle est
l'organe qui n'ont pas
de vivre le plus longtemps le
vieillissement c'est toujours une sarko
fini en repli à une perte de protéines
dans le muscle temps qu'un le
vieillissement passe toujours
prenez pas pour un gisement musculaire
sur la rivalité ce vieillissement
musculaire on ralentit considérablement
le vieillissement de l'être là et en
amont amène notre en train de démontrer
avec tout soutien d'un coup deux
européennes que non seulement le muscle
envoie tes hormones mais il envoie des
modèles génétique dans les cellules
pancréatiques et que cela était
génétique va se figer le seul progrès
tic et va permettre une mémoire de
l'activité physique en d'autres termes
si vous avez fait beaucoup de sport
entre 20 à 50 ans et que pour des
raisons x ou arrêter un moment donné
disant vous serez toujours
protégé parce que vous avez fait l'avant
alors si vous n'avez jamais fait sport
vous serez pas protégés c'est très
important parce qu'il ya une très belle
leçon de de l'imprimé le moral
le bénéfice ce que l'on tout ce que l'on
fait de bien
on le garde dans la mémoire a voté hier
dans l'histoire et l'homme on le sait
maintenant est une réserve de mémoire de
loire de ce qui a été fait de mémoire de
ce que nos aînés en fait celle du jeune
neymar que parce que nous faisons c'est
l'épigénétique et ceux ci permettent
indiscutablement de voir l'avenir d'une
autre manière
parce que c'est pas parce que par
exemple on arrêter parce que pendant
cinq ans comme un référent supporter 25
ans et on en a attrapé la mare a remis
la mémoire dans nos muscles de d'un
mutant aux cellules pancréatiques d'un
muscle qui traque et il ya effectivement
important de faire travailler l'ensemble
de ses muscles et pas forcément dans une
salle de musculation qui coûte cher etc
et je dis toujours qu'il ya deux
exercices extraordinaire c'est de passer
l'aspirateur
ça vaut pour les hommes savent le faire
et pour cela on le travaille les gens
puissent contre les bras quand pas s'en
passer en repasser on a au moins d'1
minute 30 minutes pour aspirer un
appartement
c'est ce qu'on demande il ya un autre
exercice dans le même style très bien
c'est le jardinage vous jardinez à la
fois prêtre avait rejoint aussi les bras
et c'est ça qu'il faut à tout prix
recherché ce qui est mauvais
par exemple pour une personne notamment
d'un certain âge c'est ce tapis roulant
sur un tapis roulant vous fait que les
rouler les bus que d'endurance c'est pas
bon par contre si vous à thuram heures
si vous n'êtes pas il faut vraiment très
faire dérailler l'ensemble du capital
musculaire plutôt les muscles tendus aux
cantons et shon gbagbo etc
elle est plutôt le muc de résistance
quand on dit un peu plus vieux un peu
moins moins moins attractif que c'est
vraiment deux types l'exercice très
simples qui sont en exil me séparait de
d'aller travailler pied c'est pareil de
faire de faire du vélo c'est pareil de
ya un souffle à ce que j'aime beaucoup
qui est anglais je le traduis en
français n'a sioniste bad et neething
better than the thing ne rien faire
c'est d'abord tu as des as tout ce que
l'on fait c'est mieux que ne rien faire